podcast host of The Right View Laura
Trump is with us and he first wrote uh
get Trump he has a brand new book out
today and it's called the war against
the Jews how to end hamas's barbarism
Harvard Law Professor Alan dtz is with
us and Fox News contributor Charlie
hert no Laura let me let me start with
you and I have a lot of questions for
all of you but let let's start with and
I know you're husband now for two days
in a row has had to take the stand and I
know Donald Trump Jr had had to take the
stand now in the contracts correct me if
I'm wrong at any point isn't there that
contractual provision telling lenders
telling insurance companies to use their
own numbers don't they have a fiduciary
responsibility to do it did any one of
these companies lose money did any one
of these companies complain uh because
my understanding is they did not and so
my question is why are we even here who
got hurt in any of this and if Donald
Trump is telling the lenders and telling
the insurance companies they've got to
come up with their own
valuations well that's that
responsibility is on them isn't
it you are exactly right Sean but you
just heard the best of the best from
Leticia James there when people tell you
who they are believe them and you heard
it from her right there she has never
cared actually about the people people
of New York about protecting them she
has always cared about a political
Vendetta against Donald Trump that is
what this has all been about from the
beginning and it is such a shame but at
at a time when New York is in shambles
you have crime through the roof
homelessness through the roof you have
Jewish New Yorkers so afraid for their
lives that synagogues are having to hire
armed guards and where is the top law
enforcement officer in the state of New
York sitting front row at a Civil Trial
where you just said it you have no
plaintiff you have no injured party you
have no damages it is a completely
ridiculous trial and then to add insult
to injury and just to inflict maximum
collateral damage she dragged my husband
as you just said and his siblings into
it knowing they had nothing to do with
any of this it is so sick to see what is
happening and I want to say to Leticia
James that because of you my daughter
who's 4 years old was in tears this
morning because her dad was not able to
be at her fall School show my kids
didn't get to trick-or treat with their
dad this Halloween why because of a
deranged attorney general and a case
Sean that never should have seen the
light of day you know I I want everyone
to really highlight on Professor dz's
very well said new book it's called war
against the Jews I'm going to ask him
about that but his book prior to this
was get Trump named after Leticia James
that was her campaign slogan I didn't
bake up that title that's her title do
you have to pay her any royalties or
well a counter suit might be in order
yeah but but the question is you look at
this case yeah the fiduciary what lender
is going to lend you 10 cents if they
don't do their own valuation and who
gives the Attorney General the priority
to protect Banks to protect insurance
companies that aren't complaining
they're not complaining you protect the
Ordinary People you protect the kids at
Columbia University who are being
harassed and subject to anti-Semitism
you don't protect Banks and insurance
companies who yeah Cooper Union who
aren't even complaining this is such a
contrived madeup get Trump case you know
I don't want to ever make comparisons to
Stalin the Soviet Union but when the
head of the KGB said to Stalin show me
the man and I'll find you the crime
that's what she did I have never seen it
this pad and probably now I have shown
on this show PL 2 acre ocean front plots
of land in Palm Beach okay two acres I
know this sounds crazy to everybody 2
acres of land it's just dirt there's no
house on it nothing $200 million asking
price an acre and a half on the ocean
one acre and a half and they're asking
150 million this judge 20 acres of prime
real estate uh on the inter Coastal and
the ocean with a huge historic building
and a club Association with it I mean a
minimum it's close to a billion dollar
property and the judge says no I'm going
to go with the valuation of18 million
I'll buy it I'll buy I'll buy it we'll
go into partnership we'll sell it okay
you know uh all right let Charlie let's
get you a take on all
this you know it's it's really amazing
um you know when you you know the great
thing about America is you know you have
a city like New York and it can be as
corrupt as they want they can elect
whoever they want to elect as their uh
as their uh da or their mayor or
whatever but you know the and they have
to live under those rules and under that
corruption but the problem here is that
it's expanding Way Beyond the borders of
uh New York in in that that they are
trying to bring down uh a president a
former president a a president who's
running for reelection they're trying to
prevent him from uh being a you know on
the ballot so that people can actually
vote for him because most Republicans
want vote for him again and I think a
lot of people a lot of Independence and
and uh people who are not caught up in
all of this insane insane nonsense would
like to vote for him again they'd like
to bring back the policies that Donald
Trump had but but but that you have this
these corrupt officials in New York who
are preventing the American people from
getting to a shot at this it's insane
and Laura I'll give you the last word
here so we're going to go back to 2016
we already knew about Stormy Daniels
we're going to talk about January 6th
that's okay January 2021 uh a documents
case which no other Hillary didn't have
to deal with Joe didn't have to deal
with and all these trials they want to
happen in the election year and I don't
think the president can get Fair trials
in New York or Washington DC or fton
County and where he's more likely to win
on appeal that'll happen the year after
election does that sound fair to you and
well none of it is fair Sean but
everyone can see what this is about and
you know what the the people of this
country don't care about any of that
garbage what they care about is
protecting our border they care about
being energy independent they care about
Skyhigh inflation coming back down us
regaining our standing on the world
stage and peace through strength and
they know one man can bring it to him
Donald J Trump all right thank you all
the book is called war against the Jews
Professor duritz amazon.com all right
coming up next hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else